I'll say to them religion is not
something which is actually something is
confining it's confining on a
superficial level but Islam in
particular is a religion which does take
you out of your physical and cycle
psychological or comfort zone and
spiritual comfort zone but with that you
achieve what we would call a higher
state of being highest state of
spiritual being of living and so this
short-term Horizon thinking where you
only think of immediate Pleasures this
immediacy is something which is really
the Achilles heel of most people in the
world and and the and the cause the
major cause of depression and anxiety
for the majority of people that live in
the Western Hemisphere if you enjoyed
this short clip visit the dean show TV
on YouTube to watch the full video